Hello 大家好 我是[来源标识已去除]欢迎大家来到[来源标识已去除]出品的拼多多商家成长训练营的第六节课程
多店铺注册的技巧首先跟大家去简单的去讲一下注册的流程啊
一到两分钟的时间快速的去进行过一下
第一个呢注册的地址这个地方我相信就不用[来源标识已去除]跟大家一点一点去进行说
你直接在网页端里面去搜索一下拼多多他就出来
这个地方就会有一个商家的一个入住
我就不再跟大家去进行强调了
注册的时候手机号码入住的选择
选择这个板块里面呢你们根据你们自身的一个情况
切记建议大家能注册企业类型的店铺
尽可能去注册企业店，专卖专营以及普通店
资质的一个填写
不允许有些不规范的我就不详细跟大家去进行
说了因为里面的东西其实官方给的很明确
那基本信息呢就是个人店
因为现在拼多开店很快
我给大家一个建议啊
就你们在注册这种店铺的时候啊
尽可能的啊
今天注册下个星期再用
等个三天五天八天十天左右的个时间会更好
有的人会说[来源标识已去除]去进行解释
因为你们根本就不知道我们有的时候注册店铺啊
今天注册的今天用和明天注册的下个星期用
可能会有那么一丢丢的区别啊
建议大家店铺注册完之后先把保证金交了
你别忘了去发布产品
等个三天五天八天左右的时间再去进行用啊
各地工商户也是一模一样的
最后一步呢就是开店成功啊
你去进行试试密码啊
绑定你的微信啊等等等等这些
那我就不再跟大家去进行强调了
因为注册的流程和资质填写这个板块里面
我相信你们注册店铺应该很熟悉
唯一不熟悉的就是
今天注册的店铺最好今天没用啊
下个星期用等个五天七天十天左右的时间
重点跟大家去讲一下注册的技巧
有调性分的品牌
如果你不明白你们看啊
第五节课程到底是什么样的一个调性分称为品牌啊
可一次性在一级类目里面注册期间链在50家店左右
我跟大家去进行讲一下大家可能就明白了
如果说你们的产品或者说你们的店铺或者说你们的品牌注册的时候
你们会黑标啊有点兴奋
那比如说家居生活我就要注册那你第一家店铺可能叫啊[来源标识已去除]家居生活旗舰店
比如说我这个品牌叫[来源标识已去除]啊在拼多的站内四分能上百亿补贴有真明显
我叫[来源标识已去除]家居生活旗舰店那这是第一家店那第二家店还是给这个公司
还是给营业执照因为一个营业执照可以授权八家十家十二家十六家
黑科技可能能注册一百家那么第二个企业店的名字叫什么呢换个手机号码叫[来源标识已去除]家居旗舰店啊
再往下面去走呢叫[来源标识已去除]居家日用旗舰店就是你在选择店铺名称的时候可以选择很多很多给大家的建议和经验呢
一个营业执照可以注册四至五家左右的旗舰店，就比较合适
因为黑标旗舰店相对而言权重比较高
同时呢黑标店铺对营业执照是有考核的
一般一个二级分类十到十五家左右的营业执照
你再开你的调性分可能就会被压掉
那个系统可能就会判贴牌
针对没有调性分的品牌
就是非黑标的白牌的怎么进行注册呢
好 仔细认识的去听啊
一个品牌只能注册一家旗舰店
人家专卖店里面的逻辑是一样
比如说我还是[来源标识已去除]
那我叫什么呢
叫[来源标识已去除]家居专卖店
第二个叫什么
叫[来源标识已去除]家居生活专卖店
第三个叫[来源标识已去除]居家自用专卖店
所以专营店它也是相同的一个东西
那么这个地方就会有人一个东西
问一个什么样的东西呢
就是手机号码
手机号
一个营业执照最多能注册多少家
手机号呢
我给你们的建议是主账号
建议用合规的
子账号可以不合规
什么意思呢
就是主账号
你们其实可以去你们当地去问一下
中国移动
中国电信
中国年通
你问他一下
我以公司营业执照去进行办理一个企业的宽带
大多数地方可能就几百块钱
一个月
那么拿这样的宽带呢
是可以在当地无限去申请手机号码的
且这个手机号码是非常正规的
你只要交约租就行了
你都能够去分
企业的营业执照
比如说我入职了一家公司
他老板让我去认证一个手机号码
我离职了
这个手机号码
公司随时可以把我的名字换掉
但是需要员工本人去进行认证
那么我办的是中国电信的
那么本身我这个人在中国电信有两张电话卡
他还可以帮助你公司
认证三张
所以一个营业一个家庭宽带
你办多的电话号码没办法换名字
但是一个企业的宽带
你有多少个员工
你就可以认证多少张电话卡
一般情况下都有乘以三乘以五
你有十个员工就是三十个电话号码
这只是一个中国移动
那你还可以去办明一个中国电信
还有一个中国电通
去当地去进行问
就像我公司里面大概一共办了140多张电话卡
都是员工帮我去进行认证的
但是呢我永远不用担心员工离职
因为员工只要离职
我只要跟电信的业务监理说一声
这个员工离职了
把这个号码保留
换一个身份证
新员工来了
直接去进行搞
就OK了
这个呢其实就是注册的一个技巧
紫账号呢
你就用一些什么短期的号呀
或者你在网上买的这些号
其实都OK都是没有问题的
一个营业执照最多的
你注册多少家呢
其实一个营业执照最多可以注册100家店铺
可以注册100家店铺
如果你们有这个需求
你们这一年期班主员就行了
让班主员给你堆接这样的资源
这个是外面有收费的
那么这节课就不再给大家去啰嗦了
就讲到这里
我是[来源标识已去除]
祝大家天天报单